a violent volcanic eruption in Hawaii is
threatening to cause even more
destruction this morning the Kilauea
volcano on Hawaii's Big Island has
spilled huge amounts of lava for more
than three days and nights around 1,700
people living nearby have been evacuated
because of the lava and poisonous gas
the lava has destroyed at least 31 homes
and other structures hundreds of
earthquakes have rocked the area and
more volcanic cracks opened in the
ground over the weekend Carter Evans got
a look at the conditions from the sky
he's outside Leilani estates in Pahoa
Hawaii Carter good morning good morning
this community is locked down residents
are not going inside right now in fact
emergency management put out a cell
phone warning on Sunday evening telling
everyone to get out of the neighborhood
but we understand there are some people
inside and police are not going in to
get them out from the airlines of smoke
show where lava is flowing through
Leilani estates as Homes continue to
burn up here in the helicopter you can
really get an idea of the scope of the
destruction below you don't see any fire
fighters down there because there is
nothing they can do the lava is consumed
everything in its path including trees
and homes it crept across the street and
slowly and developed this car RUP seen
you know progress a few more pretty
extensive flows seems like there's a lot
of magma
there's no sign of slowing down at least
10 fishers have opened up in Leilani
estates which is on the eastern slope of
the Kilauea volcano in some cases the
eruptions were so violent lava spewed
more than two hundred feet in the air
Sunday some evacuee own to grab
essentials a line of cars waiting to
return stretch more than two miles do
you have any idea when you'll be able to
go home again at first glance it may not
look like the lava here is moving at all
it's cooled there's a crust on top but
if you look at the leading edge here on
the road it is slowly inching forward
over the weekend the Big Island was
rocked by hundreds of earthquakes
including one measuring 6.9 Hawaii's
largest in more than 40 years it's like
a good Goliath like a roaring jet engine
Sam Knox lives about a hundred yards
away from one of the eruptions why did
you choose to stay because this is where
I live right here I had faith and faith
in the gods that my house is going to be
okay
the lava is showing no signs of slowing
down right now and that's just one of
the concerns here another is sulfur
dioxide that is a gas emitted by the
lava it can be deadly and authorities
say there are extremely high levels in
what they call the hot zone
Vlad Carter Evans in Hawaii Thank You
Carter